just talk us through what is the latest
in the city of Pearson yeah in
Hearthstone down in the southwest there
are a couple of things happening there
one is that the little spit of land
there that little strip of land you can
see opposite the the coast that's the
kinburn peninsula the ukrainians say
they've almost taken that and that's
important although it's very Sandy very
watery it gives them control over the
Estuary of the bug River and the danipro
river which controls the ability of
Kirsten and also mikalayev up the bug
River to act as ports so it opens up the
the coast for them there if they can
take that little strip of land and they
say they almost have whether they can do
anything else with it in terms of
getting more troops onto it to move into
Russian positions that's a different
issue but for now they're doing pretty
well there the city itself the still
artillery Jewels going on that we've
talked about the last few days either
side of the river and sensibly enough
now a lot of people in person are moving
out at least for a while the last 24
hours there's been a queue of cars to
get out they're just moving out probably
many of them I would guess to make a Lev
but for at least two or three weeks or
maybe more they need to get out of the
city because the city will be subject to
quite a big bombardment yeah interesting
um a lot of fighting as well that has
moved to the donbass region why is that
yeah this is really ferocious
um the the main air is fatove and
cremena up there in the uh in the north
that's that's the two main areas and in
between those two uh places there are
lots of attacks and counter attacks so
the ukrainians put in a big
counter-attack at uh
they've got quite a big Salient and the
Russians have got their own Salient just
south of that at um
and so in a way they're almost
overlapping each other they're fighting
ferociously for that area and meanwhile
further south of bakmut there they've
been attacking back mode now for four or
five weeks and even if Batman Falls if
the Russians lose cremator it won't do
them any good to take back much so we
keep asking
because the Wagner group The Mercenary
group who worked for the Russians have
taken off back much as their target and
this is all because they're also trying
to make a political point that we can
win a back mode and the leader of the
Wagner group now is a man called yevgeni
pragosin and pragosian has said in the
last couple of weeks he says we're using
Batman as a meat grinder to pull in
Ukrainian troops and kill them of course
that's the exact opposite of what is
happening because the Russians are
losing so many troops of bakmud and it's
all to do with the the Wagner group's
ambition to take one city that they can
show to the Kremlin is our Victory you
can't win victories anywhere else we
devoured a group we win a victory at
back it's a frightening inside isn't it
to the mentality of the barber group it
is and pragos in the leader of the
Wagner group
um is a very I was going to say
interesting man I mean he's um he's a
criminal he's been done nine years in
prison himself for robbery he he said at
the Wagner group a while ago and the
Wagner who worked in Africa and Syria he
admitted on the 7th of this month that
yes of course they interfered in the
American elections in 2015. uh 2016 and
2018 and the Wilder group recruit people
from the prisons and so we've got video
of him in September of this year at the
Mariel prison east of Moscow and he
makes a speech to the convicts there all
these convicts are there for murder or
violence that so there for a very long
time and he makes a speech that sounds
like something straight out of the field
in the dirt he doesn't you know the old
Hollywood film he says only God can get
you out of this prison in a coffin but I
can get you out today if you sign up
with me we will feed you we will train
you and then we'll put you on the front
lines and if you Retreat or you disobey
an order we'll shoot you out of hand no
questions asked and if you're still
alive at the end of six months you're
free you're free to go and that's the
offer he's made and more than 20 000
convicts have signed up and are now
fighting with the Wagner group and they
are dying in High numbers in back mode
frightening staff okay Michael I think
we'll see you again at next hour but for
now thank you